So, rhenium is a fairly modern element, it
was only discovered in, I think, about 1925,
so it is 80-odd years old. Your grandparents
could be older than rhenium, or at least the
discovery of rhenium. It is now becoming increasingly
important particularly in the manufacture
of aircraft engines. As you probably know
in aircraft engines you have these huge blades
that whiz round and round, and because engines
are going faster and faster at higher and
higher temperatures, they need to be stronger
and stronger. And rhenium is now an ingredient
that can be put into the metal, making the
blades that make them behave more effectively
at high temperature and this is almost leading
to a world shortage of rhenium.
So this is a sample of rhenium, ok. This is
a very, very nice metal, often used in catalysis
from the middle of the transition metal group
and here you see the very, very dark black
coloration of this very, very fine wire of
rhenium.
The chemistry of rhenium is also very interesting
and, unlike technetium, rhenium is not a highly
radioactive material so that chemists can
easily study it, there are interesting reactions
of rhenium which will, under the influence
of light turn carbon dioxide, which is a very
inert waste material, can actually be activated
and be made to react to make something more
useful and also that there are other reactions
of rhenium, which I think will become more
important in the future.